by Kennedy FBI shoots down a Freedom of
Information Act request to release files
about their investigation into Hillary
Clinton's private email server and the
reason is beyond bizarre and frankly not
don't believe it the letter from the FBI
to the lawyer who put in the FOIA
request reads in part quote you have not
sufficiently demonstrated that the
public's interest in disclosure
outweighs personal privacy interests of
the subject here with reaction and by
the way brand-new Fox contributor Tommy
Lehren is with us in Fox News
correspondent at-large Geraldo Rivera
right so Tommy's Tommy's new to Fox
Geraldo you're a fifty-year TV veteran
you know so I'm going to go to her first
all the time huh I would hope so hi
welcome aboard the Fox News Channel and
our audience is very familiar with you
you've been on a ton of times before how
would this not be in our best interest
it's in everybody's best interest to get
the truth right well of course it is and
I think that the funny part of this
whole thing is that her privacy somehow
Trump's our right to know I'm sorry when
you use a private email on a private
server your privacy rights are out the
window when you're the secretary of
state of the United States of America
you don't have privacy anymore she chose
to do this this is on her and I
personally would like to know all right
Robert
you're a lawyer subpoenaed emails now
you're also my friend let's say I
deleted 33,000 subpoenaed emails let's
say I decided to ask acid-wash the the
servers and the hard drives with bleach
but let's say I took a hammer to my
BlackBerry's and iPhones just to make
sure they don't exist and then I sent
the FBI though other devices with no SIM
cards and I hire you to protect me
what's the first thing you're gonna do
probably give me a cake with a file in
it because I'm gonna need it right not
even you could get me off of that I
would do I would do that and much more
for you but let me before I get into the
substance of your question welcome Tommy
who although I obviously disagree with
many of her political positions I think
she has intelligent she's reasonable and
she's got most importantly to me a new
True Grit so Tommy welcome welcome
aboard in terms of the substance though
of her answer and your your obvious
concerns Jon I think that this is a
néstor for republicans to get anywhere
near this this stuff it has already
destroyed the career of jason Chaffetz
who led the charge trey Gowdy who was
promising candidate heading for great
great things as maybe a senator from
South Carolina I think he's an
afterthought they were made fools of
enough with Hillary's emails that's Big
Brother we should be LDI is already
clear goal even equal justice under the
law you know people you want a two-tier
justice system I'd go to jail and she
gets off the hook and Tommy would go to
jail too
you know Shawn if Pugh is going to go to
jail she would have gone to jail when
James Comey in the summer of 2016
announced there's nothing criminal there
but extreme careless enough already hung
instrument is going out the other jock
you'd go after her although take a mom
we made it yeah I have I have some
friends that spend a few hours and
Benghazi would really like to know was
in those emails they really like to know
why she deleted them so to say that the
public doesn't have a right to know or
that we're not interested that's a load
of crap number one number two how do we
make a deal how about when the
mainstream media stops covering Russia
day in and day out maybe we can drop the
Hillary email scandal but until then I
think I'm gonna stay on it two points
number one with real quick with all due
modesty I was almost killed in Benghazi
Libya I know the turf pretty well and I
don't I don't take a backseat to anyone
when it comes to that regard
Russia is another big yawner I totally
agree I think this guy mania my Imran 21
this is the guy they should check out is
the possible collude ur on on the leaks
with WikiLeaks you know the the guy who
worked for a Debbie wasserman-schultz
I think there is fertile grounds for
investigation probe forward
forget about history and the sordid
history in political history go forward
what is the what was the DNC hiding why
did Debbie wasserman-schultz what was
everybody this guy now accused a bunch
of the leading mouse oh that are
subpoenaed all right Tommy welcome
aboard
Geraldo you're gonna have your hands
full in the days and weeks ahead event
at Tommy's going after you my job just
got so easy good to see you both Tommy
welcome aboard good to have you